okay moving on
um there's a question from
[Music]
agvelt
asking are there any chess engines
which try to play into opponent's
specific weaknesses
um i mean there's a lot of chess engines
which will
take advantage of
the players like
weakness of blundering pieces
i saw recently there is a new
leela thing
yeah it's this thing
i send this a challenge
let's just do like five three plus two
okay
i'm playing an engine thing
so this is an engine
from the uk
which
plays like leela chess
but also
plays the bong cloud
so
[Music]
i heard of this like
i think
less than 24 hours ago
i'm gonna play one game and we'll see
oh i got a boarded what
never mind
i was so confused why i can't play e4
wait
okay i got the game
i don't know what happened there
uh let's play d4
so it's pawn clouding okay
um
so this should be much better for me
oh this will be interesting
[Music]
and move back to so now that just can't
castle
uh let's develop
so in some sense it's just giving me
some odds like it wasted a couple tempe
it can't castle
[Music]
with all that said it's still like a 3
000
plus rated
engine which is probably going to
destroy me
but we'll see if i can survive
i feel like a4 is a useful move
just trying to clamp down on the queen
side
and if i can draw i feel like that will
be a a reasonable result
i am trying to preserve time here just
okay put pieces on good squares
wow it's g5
okay i'm not afraid i'm just gonna
develop like a
a principled person
giving me a free pawn
i guess there's uh e5
wow knight c6 is kind of interesting
if i play d5 there's 94
h5 is coming so
i might not be winning the pawn
i could maybe consider moving back and
going for f3
even f3 right away
there's also this move knight e2 c3
maybe i'll just try and play like very
solidly
maybe some eventual f3
bishop g5
i have to watch my time too
[Music]
okay let's play knight
h5 is coming
[Music]
i'll play c3
e5 wow
i'll play knight g3
rig f1
some moves it just makes so quickly
i mean
f7 is a bit weak
h4 is coming
i take
probably not
uh what to do
before i i feel like i'm already getting
outplayed
if i take and
play this
i do a 92
[Music]
take that
wow
[Music]
okay i just want to trade queens
oh e3 hangs but
okay now it's getting crazy
this
oh no i got fourth
i have this move though
ah it's not helping
oh my bishop
oh it's taking its sweet time too
[Music]
me ah
there goes my king
wow
it played so interestingly this g5 move
i feel so defeated where did i go wrong
[Music]
yeah it felt like after knight h6 like
black just has everything under control
i just didn't have enough time to
exploit f7 and h4 came
very very quickly
stockfish even says i'm i'm worse at
this point
that's so
crazy apparently c3 was too slow
[Music]
engine says knight c4
yeah i guess this makes sense to keep a
a minor piece on e3 rather than have to
take with pawn
assume that f1 is also
[Music]
playable
[Music]
wondering if there is an easier way to
exploit black like king e7
maybe i should do some opening
preparation here
i play knight c3 i guess c4 makes sense
just grab as much space as possible
and then play this
but it's only plus two
okay anyway that was fun i hope uh
people enjoyed watching me suffer
get crushed by the
leela bong clown
um maybe i'll do more of this in the
future